Centuries ago, in a small tucked away kingdom, ruled a royal family.
The family was known for rich land, blossoming mint and cocoa bean supplies.
The crown prince was set to marry the neighboring and much more powerful kingdom's daughter.
However, there was one open secret throughout the kingdom.
The prince and his maid were... in relations.
Everyone in the palace knew, but kept the information away from the princess, for they knew she could have a temper.
Until one night, the princess dropped by without warning and caught the prince.
While the princess set the kingdom ablaze in a jealous rampage, the valiant prince stood by his lover and fought for their right to love.
Or so you would think.
Instead, the prince buckled under the first sign of trouble and immediately threw his maid away to save his skin.
And while burning at the stake, the maid uttered a curse upon the land and vowed to...
Ugh, I can't believe I'm having to study today of all days.
I really shouldn't have procrastinated this history report.
But when my oshi said she's going to be making a big announcement, I can't miss it.
I'm so excited.
Oh, it could be a new song or a new outfit.
I can't even focus on this book.
I just hope it starts soon.
Ah, oh my god, oh my god!
Oh, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, kyou mo kawaii!
Ah, ah, is this thing on?
Kawaii, oh!
Good morning!
Marinara and cheese, a perfect blend of meat.
I'm a maid you'll want to wrap around your fork and eat on up.
A meal even a college student can make.
I'm Spaghetti!
Ah, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti!
Everybody, with my lovely group of girls, anything is possible.
But now it's my turn to follow a different recipe.
And that's why I am announcing my graduation from Kidney Dreamers!
Huh?
Graduation?
No way, no way, no way.
This can't be happening.
Spaghetti-chan!
No way, no way, no way.
This is just a bad dream.
Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan!
SPAGHETTI!